[Música]
ah
el día que me convocaron para reemplazar
a la profesora de matemática
estrenando mi título docente
con la emoción y la alegría
de estar en el primer trabajo
en el ámbito que elegí y para el que me
formé
el director de la escuela me acompañó al
aula mientras caminábamos dijo
ahora aplicará lo que aprendió en el
profesorado
todos estos estudiantes tienen que
aprender la matemática que usted enseña
y agregó dije todos
abrió la puerta del aula con un gesto
amable me invitó a pasar
y se fue
entré y vi
36 pares de ojos que me miraban
el todos del director
resonó fuerte en mí
y ya estaba en la docencia
como estrategia de desarrollo
me gustaba destacar aspectos de cada
concepto que enseñaba
el recurso de los lápices de color había
resultado útil para mis apuntes en el
tiempo de estudio y quería compartirlo
con los alumnos
en una clase
mientras escribía con tizas de colores
en el pizarrón verde un alumno que
habitualmente se entretenía mirando
hacia la ventana lanzando papelitos o
molestando a la compañera dijo
use otra tiza profesora siempre trae
esas usted
intérprete que se refería que yo usaba
trozos pequeños de tiza por lo que
cambié por un trozo de mayor tamaño
cuando escribí y repitió lo mismo
aumentando el tono de disgusto
hasta casi agresivo
en el recreo conversé con él me confirmó
que padecía discromatopsia
congénita
esta anomalía de la visión también
llamada daltonismo es más común en los
varones que en las mujeres
el ojo es ciego al color
desde que abren sus ojos a la vida ven
la realidad sin colores o con algún olor
y están desafiados
continuamente puesto que en la mayoría
de las referencias usamos color
semáforo señales de peligro
luces en los cargadores de baterías
las boletas de las elecciones
en la actualidad se han desarrollado
lentes que son útil para algún tipo de
discretos ya y permiten destacar un
color entre otros
desarrollan normalmente su vida mientras
construyen su propia paleta de colores
tengo que enseñar matemática
matemática es bella es desafiante es
divertida y está haciendo
es la poesía de las ideas lógicas
dijo einstein
es una ciencia
de relaciones patrones repetitivos
lenguaje simbólico
la observación es importante y hay
alumnos que no ven lo que yo veo
dirigimos los ojos al mismo pizarrón y
no ve lo que yo veo
y todos del director siguió resonando en
mí
hasta hoy
aún fuera de las aulas
reflexiones sobre el tema
todos vemos los colores en el arco iris
de qué color son las flores del
jacarandá
las luces del atardecer
el cielo es azul
y si escribo con tiza blanca
sobre pizarrón verde o negro
o un soft marcador negro sobre
superficie blanca
todos ven como yo veo el desarrollo de
ecuaciones y teoremas
y el maravilloso
entramado de las soluciones analíticas
en la página del libro
el docente recibe su título y empieza a
aprender
en matemática los problemas se resuelven
uno a uno como es la vida
acepte el desafío
me propuse sembrar esperanza y tratar
que se aprenda lo que me corresponde
enseñar
el aula hizo un recorte de la realidad
cada niño adolescente
joven adulto que sigue al aula llega con
sus saberes sus ilusiones
sus alegrías
sus angustias sus miedos
si estoy atenta a la mirada del otro
descubro
tempranamente su interés o su desánimo y
así puedo alentar a un paso atrás para
desandar
aprendiendo
no es castigo no es debilidad
repetir o rehacer lo hecho para
mejorarlo
o puedo animar a un paso adelante y
lanzarlo a logros nunca esperados
desde la mirada
descubrir
que se puede alentar
a animar
acariciar o mostrar desagrado o hastío
mirar
mirarnos
mirar lo necesario y lo superfluo
mirar
la vida
aquí el día de mi camino docente vi a
los alumnos con el paso del tiempo
aprendí a mirarlos ellos me enseñaron
aprendemos unos de otros
siempre
estamos hechos de retazos son los
aprendizajes que vamos haciendo junto a
los que nos encontramos en cualquier
lugar
descubrí otra forma de entender al mundo
más allá de las diferencias nos une algo
mayor
somos distintos
siendo iguales en dignidad
estamos todos en este planeta
contando las vueltas que damos al sol
en este tiempo
breve
único que tenemos
para vivir
mirábamos la vida
[Aplausos]
e
[Música]